thirty thousand feet nine thousand one
hundred and forty four meters nine
kilometers or five point seven miles so
far only one person has survived a
freefall from that height would you be
as lucky this is what if and here's what
would happen if you fell out of an
airplane at 30,000 feet on January 26th
1972 an explosion aboard j8e Airways
flight 367 resulted in the impossible 22
year old flight attendant vesna vulovic
fell from 10,000 meters in the air
setting a world record for surviving the
highest fall without a parachute how did
she survive is there a trick to falling
out of an airplane and surviving and
what does it feel like if you're a
frequent flyer you might want to pay
close attention to what's coming up
since the 1940s there have been almost
50 cases of people surviving Falls from
airplanes in all of those cases the
survivors were lucky enough to have
something to cushion their fall vesna
vulovic for example was in the back of
the plane when the explosion happened
when the plane broke apart the tail
section remained intact and pinned by a
food cart volovich was prevented from
being sucked out into the open air the
detached tail of the airplane landed in
deep snow in the mountains of
Czechoslovakia volovich suffered several
broken bones but the airplane wreckage
and layers of deep soft snow ultimately
saved her life the second highest fall
without a parachute that someone
survived happened in 1943 air force
gunner Alan McGee's bomber was hit by
enemy fire over France his plane burst
into flames and propelled Magee out of
the plane before he could grab a
parachute Magee fell about 6700 meters
apparently he smashed through the glass
roof of a train station and was found
hanging from the steel girders that held
up the roof you wouldn't think that a
glass roof would cushion any kind of
fall but if it hadn't have been there
Magee might not have survived so if you
ever find yourself falling from an
airplane without a parachute grab on to
something anything and use it to break
your fall of course that's easier said
than done when you're in freefall from
nine thousand one hundred and forty-four
meters in the air a soft landing is
probably the last thing on your mind it
all happens so fast from the moment
you're outside the plane it's only 170
seconds until you hit the ground during
that time you will be extremely cold and
deprived of oxygen
the average temperature at nine thousand
one hundred and forty-four meters in the
sky ranges between minus 40 degrees to
minus 57 degrees but you wouldn't feel
it for long because you'd pass out soon
after leaving the aircraft while all air
contains 20.9% oxygen at higher
altitudes there is lower air pressure so
it feels as if there's a lot less oxygen
this will cause you to lose
consciousness at least for a while the
air pressure will gradually rise as you
get closer to the ground
you would probably wake up again after
about a minute of freefall as you fall
your speed will increase by 9.8 meters
per second every second because that's
the Earth's gravity eventually you would
stop accelerating and reach a constant
speed known as terminal velocity this
results from a buildup of air pressure
below you as you fall because air can't
get out of your way fast enough and at
the same time the air behind you doesn't
fill in fast enough creating a sort of
vacuum the difference in the air
pressure below you and the air pressure
above you creates drag or air resistance
when the force exerted by this air
resistance equals the force of gravity
you've reached terminal velocity and
you'll be moving at a constant speed
falling from 30,000 feet you're likely
to reach terminal velocity at 190 km/h
of course your actual terminal velocity
will depend on your size and weight the
heavier you are the faster you'll fall
but if you spread your arms and legs out
wide you can increase the amount of drag
exerted on you that might slow you down
a bit you'd enjoy it a lot more if you
had a parachute though parachutes are
lightweight and very wide a parachute
would cut your falling speed from 45
meters per second down to about 5 meters
per second if you don't have a parachute
it would help to know where to land look
for somewhere that's soft so if there's
a chance of breaking your fall a lot of
people who have fallen from airplanes
and lived have survived due to landing
in deep snow or being cushioned by trees
or bushes unfortunately a tree can
either be really good or really really
bad if you don't see anything soft below
your best bet is to try to land feet
first with your legs together slightly
bent when you hit the ground you'll
likely crumple to the side or back
this is known as the five-point impact
sequence and while it will be incredibly
painful it will save everything above
your waist mainly your vital organs and
your brain of course these are all just
recommendations tips to make the best
out of a bad and severely unlucky
situation humans aren't really built for
9,000 144 meter free Falls and yet every
year we seem to achieve something that
we thought was impossible so before your
next flight you might want to pack a
four-leaf clover just in case and for
more ways to survive freak accidents
paranormal activities or apocalyptic
events just keep watching what if